مرحبًا بلقائك الرائع اليوم ، سعدت
بلقائك ومبروك على مباراة اليوم
كانت مباراة اليوم سهلة مقارنة
بالأمس على الأقل ما حدث بالأمس جيدًا أه
أعني
لا أحب أن أقول إنها كانت مباراة سهلة
أو ربما لأنها كانت
غير محترمة قليلاً  بالنسبة للخصم ،
أشعر وكأنني لعبت على
مستوى أعلى أو ربما بمستويين أعلى
مما كنت قد لعبت فيه الليلة الماضية ، لذا تعلم
الليلة الماضية أنها كانت أول مباراة
بعد إصابة قادمة إلى دبي ، فأنت تعلم أنك
لا تلعب أي حدث.  لأكثر من
شهر ، كان آخرها
نهائيات بطولة أستراليا المفتوحة ، لذا فأنت تعلم أنني ما زلت أتدرب
وأحاول الوصول إلى حالة أكثر لياقة ، لذا
سأكون قادرًا على لعب أفضل تنس ،
وكنت أعرف أنني ربما لن أكون 100 كما
تعلم.  قادمة إلى مباراة الأمس
وكنت آمل فقط أنه مع
تقدم المباراة أو مع
تقدم البطولة ، سأكون قادرًا على رفع
المستوى الذي حدث بالفعل اليوم ، كنت
قريبًا جدًا من أفضل ما لدي ، تعرف 6250 كما تعلم
في أقل من ساعة  كنت ألعب بشكل جيد للغاية وأنا
أتحرك بشكل رائع ،
لذا الكثير من الإيجابيات لأخذها من
الليلة وآمل أن آخذها إلى أه
للتحدي التالي بشكل أفضل نعم ،
ونأمل أن نراك في النهائي ،
ما رأيك في
الدفع لك مثل  حولها
ما الذي لا نحبه في دبي
أعني أنها واحدة من أفضل المدن
في العالم ولا شك أنك تعرف واحدة من
أهم المدن التي كانت على هذا النحو
لأكثر من 10 سنوات ولكن أعني أنني أشعر
أنني في آخر خمس سنوات  سنوات
نمت دبي كثيرًا ولديها
وجهة مهمة للرياضة من أجل
السياحة التي تعرفها للابتكار في
كل شيء
ومطاعم مدهشة جدًا تعرف
وقت الشاطئ إذا كنت ترغب في
السباحة ، مناخ رائع للغاية على مدار السنة
وأنت تعرف  دائمًا ما يطارد لاعبي التنس
الشمس بطريقة تعرف أننا
رياضة صيفية في الهواء الطلق ، لذا فإن
قاعدة التدريب هنا في دبي جيدة
كما تعلم ، لذلك هناك الكثير من
لاعبي التنس من الرجال والنساء المقيمين في
دبي للتدريب في دبي كما تعلم  لقد كنت
هنا قبل بضعة أشهر قبل ذهابي
إلى أستراليا لبضعة أسابيع ، أه تدريب
حتى تعرف أنني أحب دبي فقط والناس
هي دولية جدًا ، لذا يتابع الناس
رياضة التنس ، إنها
أجواء رائعة في الملعب المركزي
للبطولة  هذا تاريخي للغاية وناجح
للغاية في جولة اتحاد لاعبي التنس المحترفين ، لذا الآن
ثلاثة
أسابيع 178 كأول مرة ، ما الذي
أشعر به ليس فقط أن أكون رقم واحد ولكن
أيضًا كل تلك الأسابيع إنه رائع
حقًا ، أنا ممتن جدًا
لإمكانية الوصول  أنت تعرف أن
سجل Steffi Graf
الذي بدا يتعذر الوصول إليه ، كما تعلم منذ سنوات ،
لكنك تعلم عندما تجاوزت
Rogers Record منذ بعض الوقت لمدة 310
أسبوعًا ، شعرت بأنني بخير لأنك تعرف ما إذا
كنت بصحة جيدة إذا كنت تعرف الاستمرار في اللعب
بشكل جيد  كنتيجة جيدة لذلك ،
كنت أفكر في ذلك ، لقد فعلت ذلك ،
أعني أنني دائمًا أعتبر نفسي
طالبًا جيدًا في اللعبة ، كما تعلم ، أنا
أحترم كل العظماء الرجال والنساء
الذين مهدوا الطريق  بالنسبة لنا جميعًا كما
تعلمون وبالطبع
أم ، لذا فأنا أظهر تقديريًا كبيرًا لذلك وأنت تعلم
أنني ما زلت
متفاجئًا قليلاً أيضًا لأنني
أذهب بهذه القوة التي تعرفها في هذا العمر
بعد سنوات عديدة لذلك أنا  م أنت تعرف
محاولة
استخدام أه قدر ما أستطيع من هذا الزخم
والبقاء بصحة جيدة وأبذل قصارى جهدي في
كل مكان أتنافس فيه.
مصطلحات التنس أو الرياضة التي هي بالفعل
قديمة جدًا على الرغم من أنني لا أحب
حساب العمر أو النظر إليه بهذه الطريقة ، لكنك
تعلم أنه بعد 30 عامًا ،
سيتقاعد الجميع بالفعل ، كما تعلم متى
سيتقاعدون جيدًا.  إعادة
عد الأيام ولكن
هل هذا يزعجك في الواقع ، أردت
أن أسألك عن هذا الحديث كله
عن التقاعد لا ليس كثيرًا
لأكون صادقًا ، فأنا أشعر أنني بحالة جيدة في
جسدي ، أشعر أنني بحالة جيدة في ذهني في قلبي ،
أعني أنا  ما زلت أحب هذه اللعبة لقد
دعمت أفراد العائلة المقربين في
حياتي لدي فريق جيد وأنت تعلم أن
لدي رغبة كبيرة في الاستمرار حتى تعرف
أولاً أنني أحب الرياضة
وثانيًا أحب المنافسة حقًا
أعتقد أنها مهمة لأنك أنت  تعرف أن
شيئًا واحدًا هو أن تحب ممارسة الرياضة
من أجل الرياضة داخل نعم أيضًا
تحتاج إلى أن يكون لديك أهداف وتفاني
احترافي في أسلوب حياة
لاعب التنس الذي يتطلب الكثير من
المتطلبات ، فهو أطول موسم في جميع
الرياضات ولكن بعد تحقيق 22 مباراة.
ينتقد
378 أسبوعًا باعتباره رقم واحد 93 لقبًا من بطولة ATP ،
ما الذي تطمح إليه لتحقيق
المزيد والمزيد من الانتصارات في المزيد والمزيد من البطولات ، المزيد من
الأسابيع ، أعني تحطيم المزيد من الأرقام القياسية
لقد أنعم الله على
الموهبة بالتأكيد ، لكنك
تعلم أيضًا بإمكانية صنع
تاريخ للرياضة التي أعطتني
كل شيء في حياتي ، لذلك يجب أن
أبذل قصارى جهدي حتى
اليوم الأخير.  هل تعلم أنك ما
زلت قويًا والأول في
العالم وليس لدي أي نية للتوقف
الآن ربما آه ربما عندما لا
أكون في مرتبة عالية جدًا أو عندما أفقد
الدافع ربما عندما أرى أن
الشباب هم
أركل مؤخرتي أكثر قليلاً ثم ربما
سأبطئ ، لكن في الوقت الحالي أنا
بخير بشكل عام أنت تقول
أنك بخير ونعم أنت بالتأكيد
أكثر من بخير أنت تقوم بعمل رائع
أنت تقوم بعمل رائع جسديًا
وكذلك عقليًا كما أنك تقوم بعمل رائع الآن ،
فأنا دائمًا أنظر إليك أثناء المباريات
حتى عندما تكون محبطًا ، أعني عقليًا
أنك هناك فقط وتستعيد
كيف تفعل ذلك
إذا كنت تريد  لإعطاء نصيحة لنا فقط ،
نعم ، يبقى هنا في هذه الغرفة
جيدًا ، لا توجد جرعة سرية واحدة
لذلك أو الصيغة ، إنها حقًا
مزيج من الأشياء المختلفة أشعر
أن كل شيء يبدأ بالطبع
بفهم شخصيتك أو
شخصيتك من أنت
وماذا  هي نقاط قوتك ، ما هي ربما
نقاط ضعفك ، ما هي الأشياء التي
يجب عليك العمل عليها مع
الجميع بطريقة تتفاعل بشكل
مختلف قليلاً مع
ظروف معينة في الملعب ، ربما تحت
الضغط ، ربما يكون البعض على دراية
بالتشديد ، والبعض يشبه مجرد تقديم كل شيء
لذلك يعتمد الأمر حقًا وأعتقد أنه
مزيج من أشياء مثل ، على سبيل
المثال ، تجربة أن أكون أه في
هذا الموقف المحدد
مرات عديدة في مسيرتي المهنية ، لذا كلما كنت هناك أكثر
كلما شعرت براحة أكبر في كل
مرة أخرى ولكن في نفس الوقت
إنها مجرد قوة
إرادة لا تصدق أشعر أنها
هي المفتاح الذي تعرفه ، فأنا كما لو كنت
لا تقبل الهزيمة ، فأنت
لا تقبل بالفشل ، لكنها لا
تعمل دائمًا ، كما تعلم أحيانًا
أنك تفشل  لكن أو تعلم أن هذا يعجبني
أكثر من الفشل أه لكنك تعلم أنني كنت
محظوظًا لأن غالبية المرات التي
قمت فيها بعمل جيد في تلك
الظروف لقد قمت بعمل جيد جدًا ، ما
رأيك في النقاش
حول من هو الماعز أو أعظم
لاعب ، ما رأيك في ذلك
على الرغم من المقارنة الكاملة بينك
فيدرر ونادال ،
ما رأيك في
مفضلتي الشخصية ، لا أعني من هو
المفضل لديك شخصيًا ، هذا هو
المفضل لدي شخصيًا ، نعم هناك رجل واحد فقط
من  صربيا
انظر أولاً ، يجب أن أقول إنني
محظوظ حقًا لوجودي في هذا
النقاش
وقد يعتقد الناس أنك تعلم أنه
هذا النوع من التواضع المزيف ولكنني حقًا
لأنك تعلم فقط بالنظر إلى
البدايات وأين بدأت
وكيف  لقد وصلت إلى هنا ، إنها حقًا
رحلة لا تصدق ، إنها قصة رائعة ولن أعرف أن
أقول إنني
الأفضل أو أنه الأفضل أو أيًا كان ما سأسمح
للآخرين بمناقشته أنني
سأحاول أن أكون دائمًا
نسخة أفضل من نفسي وأن أكون
سفيرًا أفضل للرياضة لأنه في
نهاية اليوم ، تقع على عاتقك
مسؤولية أن يتابعك الكثير من الأشخاص حول العالم بصفتك لاعبًا بارزًا
وشخصًا صنع تاريخًا للرياضة.
رياضة التنس العالمية للغاية ،
لذا عليك
دائمًا أن تحاول دائمًا أن تكون سفيرًا جيدًا
للتنس وأن تجعل المزيد من الأشخاص
يشاركون في لعب المزيد من الأطفال ، وهذا شيء
يثيرني كثيرًا ، أود أن أقول
لك شكرًا جزيلاً لك على وقتك ،
شكرًا لك  أقدر ذلك شكرا لك